avec l'avancée de l'âge il est important
de rappeler certaines règles sur les
dangers de la route
les seniors ont participé à divers
ateliers simulateurs de voitures
actualisation des connaissances du code
de la route gestes qui sauvent ou encore
parcours lunettes alcool on est vraiment
très mal je n'ai pas bu je ne bois pas
régulièrement et j'avais l'impression
d'être sur un bateau des pompiers des
spécialistes de la police nationale et
de la sécurité routière ont échangé avec
les seniors l'ambiance était détendue
pourtant l'enjeu était de taille
véhiculer des messages adaptés aux
seniors de plus en plus touchés la taux
de mortalité sur la route chez les
seniors a fortement augmenté dans le
département ces dernières années on est
passé à +18 % en quelques années et
surtout pour les plus de 75 ans les
responsables de la sécurité routière
souhaite sensibiliser les seniors sur
leur capacité à prévenir d'éventuelles
difficultés
on a eu beaucoup d'accidents de
seigneurs piétons sont les accidents ou
en fait un seigneur s'était engagé sur
la chaussée n'a pas fait attention à un
poids lourd et s'est retrouvé dans
l'angle mort du poids lourds et le poids
lourd l'a écrasée du coup ça c'est un
message à faire passer effectivement
dire aux piétons pas qu'aux seniors
attention au poids lourds ils n'ont pas
les mêmes champs de vision qu'une
automobile et donc ils peuvent ne pas
vous voir quand vous êtes sur la
chaussée
cette action originale a retenu
l'attention des principaux intéressés
une cinquantaine de personnes étaient
présentes trouve c'est très intéressant
parce que quand on vieillit on n'est pas
aux dernières nouvelles au point de vue
code de la route surtout au point de vue
performances ça fait du bien de se
remettre en question
les informations complémentaires sur les
dangers de la route sont à retrouver sur
le site internet de la sécurité routière